oh je soussigné lucien morel conseiller
municipal informe que c'est dans les
tons fille ciel informe que les missions
des shadoks qui sont auteurs doivent
être internés parmi les faibles d'esprit
une autre lettre maintenant au siècle où
nous sommes cette émission conviendrait
mieux et des débiles mentaux
voilà mon opinion de médecin je suis
attardé mental
ma femme est débile prête en france on
devrait
mais on n échappe évidemment nombreux
sont ceux qui réclament autre chose et
cette lettre en est un exemple je
voulais lee donnez nous des émissions
éducatives plutôt que ces folies nous
voulons des jeux des concours instructif
répondre à la question
on est à venir
de père la rigueur
yahoo
je vais
les marins refuse de participer à des
émissions complètement absurde ouais
remanier la maison ce qui est encore
plus pénible c'est de voir qu'avec notre
argent on paie grassement les employés
pour qu'ils ne nous donne pas
satisfaction un vrai patron n'accepterai
pas ça et c'est vrai dans toutes les
lettres les gens disent nous payons
notre redevance par conséquent nous
sommes les patrons des gens qui sont à
l'horaire tf
nous avons 40 millions de bâton
m
moi
le genre
là
fm
m
yeah
you
ceci se passe de commentaires nous avons
quand même des lettres pauvre monsieur
je suis partisan du maintien de
l'émission des shadoks pour les motifs
suivants en raison de ses autres
qualités esthétiques intellectuelle et
morale parce que son interprète la même
voie que celle de mon curé et que je
prends désormais un intérêt accru aux
sermons dominicaux signée jean calinaud
avec ab c'est un laïc doit aller bien
amen et inchallah pour ne mécontenter
personne